[Music]
i'm working on some [ __ ] so i've been
harder to get to [ __ ] out here
worried about the business that i tend
to but they don't want no
smoke and it's clear then it's settled
i'm looking at these views though
i need my space like pluto i got him in
his feelings he can't knock it if it's
true though
now that i'm popping he'd probably want
me for the cool i don't know about it
all but here's some [ __ ] that i do know
you learn off experience so ain't no
point in fearing it [ __ ] got serious i
had to get it period
some say i'm cocky others say i'm
mysterious i say i'm bout to bag it if
not then i ain't hearing it
yeah because your girl came a long way
and working 9-5 wasn't worth it for the
small change
back in school i was rapping in them
hallways and even animals move like
butter they called it parquet
i get my [ __ ] off for hoes that i piss
off you ain't bringing nothing to the
table you could get lost
boss moves with the big talking can't
nobody say they gave me nothing [ __ ]
i've been on my [ __ ] been hard
a lot of speculating i don't blame them
blowing up my damn but i still don't
entertain them i'm focused on this money
baby why you gotta play dumb i'm proud i
made it out from the places that i came
from and look at what it's doing
these visions i'm pursuing it's just a
little way to leave the young bulls
influence
and i don't sweat the little things
cause really i be cooling i run my own
[ __ ] so they watch how i get into it
it's me
[Music]